I get an order of 10,000 about that
around there's a lot of boxes
I guess ups got fed up we not picking up
the packages they just dropped them all
in once I'm in front of my [ __ ] house
which is why I sent you that picture
yeah it was one two three four five six
ten boxes huge boxes of I don't know
what I'm what is this I thought it was
like I don't know what I don't know what
I thought it was but I thought was a I
thought was a mistake I open up the
boxes and each box had just just full of
baby wipes and on my eyes one okay this
next one baby Mike don't tell me full of
baby wipes yeah well you've done this
before - right I did three I hate Percy
waited for his birthday I hit Chelsea
and I got annoying as [ __ ] me my
daughter just got an argument the box
comes my Groban has OCD and when the box
came she was like who sent these I'm
like I think it was handle or she goes
why would he do that why'd he do that I
think he's just trying to help with this
oh I don't know make it with comedians I
don't like I say that we're comedians it
was what we do she don't understand
while we do that I was like baby just go
out I'll take care of the boxes and at
that point the baby started crying the
baby was crying and she was mad I'm like
oh the worst nights of my life